[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK BUTCHER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Nick Butcher.
I'm a designer and
engineer at Google,
and I'm also a vector addict.
And I've got five minutes to
tell you some about-- about
some of the advanced
features of Vector Drawables,
Android's vector format
supports, so let's get started.
So I posit that most
assets in your applications
should be vectors these days.
Vectors are awesome.
They're sharp on every
single density display.
They're very small.
They compress well, so
they don't blow your ADK.
But they're also
extremely flexible,
and I want to talk
about this a bit
today so you can
get the most out
of vectors to realize these
benefits as widely as possible.
So most vectors in
your app probably
look something like this.
They have some paths,
and they're probably
hard-coding a color, something
like this fill or stroke here.
Maybe you're using a
color resource like this.
But there's actually a
lot more you can do here,
which I want to talk about.
The first thing is
using theme colors.
So you can use theme
colors in two ways, really.
The first is by applying
a theme color as a tint.
This will tilt the
entire drawable
based on the current theme.
So here, I'm using the theme
attribute ColorControlNormal,
which is the normal
color for icons,
and as such, you can have one
single asset which displays
in different themes, say a
light screen or a dark screen,
and it gets tinted to
be the right color.
You no longer have to
worry what color asset you
got from your
designers in the SVG,
that they've got exactly
the right shade of gray
that you need.
It'll be tinted at runtime,
so it is always correct.
You can also use theme colors
directly in the fill or stroke.
So in this example here, I'm
going to use color primary.
So say you have different
screens in your app--
say, a sports app which uses
a theme for a given team.
You can reference
that theme color,
so you can have a
single drawable, which
just parts of it get colored
based on the theme, which
can be useful.
Cool, that was theme colors.
Next up, ColorStateLists.
So in vector support I'm
resting ColorStateLists,
you can do some fun stuff.
So in this example, and on press
state, we're changing color,
or perhaps you have
a list app, where
when a row item is selected,
you could have it change
the rendering using that state.
You could do this with
a normal stateless
drawable and two drawables
and flip between them.
But if, say, the
rendering is 99% the same,
you just want change
the stroke here,
this saves some duplication.
You define it like this,
like a regular ColorStateList
in your color resources and
refer to it, as you would,
like a color resource.
And last, my favorite
feature is gradients.
So vectors support three
different types of gradients--
linear, radial, and sweep--
which you define like this.
So a linear gradient has a
start and end x, y coordinates.
A radial has a
center and a radius,
and a sweep just
has a center point.
I've so far been using the
shorthand of start, end,
or even center colors
to define gradients,
but you can actually get
much more fine grained
and embed these item tags inside
it to define individual color
stops.
So here, I'm going
for a specific color
at 72% of the way through.
Like ColorStateLists, you define
gradients in a color resource
directory, or you can use
the inline resource syntax
to embed it inside the
vector definition itself.
And at build time,
AAPT will actually
extract that to a color resource
and insert a reference to it
for you, which is handy.
So gradients have been super
handy in building apps.
Here's an illustration from
a [INAUDIBLE] IO app, which
if we'd made it as
a gradient, would
be-- with gradient support,
would have been 1/5
the size of the
[INAUDIBLE] we had to ship
and sharp everywhere.
It's really useful for
things like adaptive icons
because, unfortunately, vectors
don't support drop shadows,
but you can fake it a lot
of the time using gradients.
Or if you need to build
something like a customized
spinner, this is really
trivial to achieve
using a radial gradient.
So gradients only
support certain shapes,
like this linear, radial, and
sweep, but paths in vectors
can be transformed,
like rotated and so on.
So in this example, I wanted to
create this oval shaped shadow
beneath the jetpack Droid.
So I did this by drawing a
circle with a radial gradient,
and then using the
scale y feature
to transform it to produce
the effect that I was after.
If the gradient you define
doesn't fill the entire shape
you're drawing to, you can use
the Tile mode to control how
it fills the rest of the area.
So in this example, the
default mode of Clamp,
it just continues
the color outwards.
If you use a repeat mode, it'll
repeat between the gradient,
going back--
continuing it.
Or a mirror mode will go back
and forth through the gradient.
You can also use
gradients which don't
go through different
colors, so by using
the same color between two
stops and having the next stop
start the same point, you can
have these solid color blocks.
Why would you want a gradient
that doesn't do that?
Well, you can have some fun
with some pretty cool effects.
So this example of a rainbow
is with one single shape
using a radial gradient with
these solid color stops.
You can do something
like a loading spinner,
or you can combine
it with a tile mode
to make some kind
of pattern support.
So this is the gradient
over this area,
and the pattern--
the tile mode repeats
it to give you a
pattern, and you
can have some fun
doing something
like animating it to produce
this kind of loading effect.
So hopefully, I've shown you
that vectors are sharp, small,
and extremely flexible, so
you can use them everywhere.
As a final example, I want to
show you what you can build.
This is a single
animated vector drawable
drawn by the amazing
Virginia [INAUDIBLE],,
and I had the pleasure
of animating it.
So this is one vector drawable,
extremely small, extremely
sharp in every display.
You can have some fun with them.
So that's Vector Drawables.
Thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]